[Música]
ele começou um com a morte de 100
milhões de pessoas mais de 50 milhões de
refugiados nas duas grandes guerras do
século passado
eu convido vocês a votarem para esse
momento
muitos casos de tortura perseguições e
humilhações perversidades campos de
extermínio campos de concentração
eu estive em auschwitz e nada é tão
triste quanto aquilo pessoas morrerem
por serem quem eram bebês judeus
morrerem por serem judeus testemunhas de
jeová sendo perseguidas toda a
comunidade lgbt sendo perseguida indo
para campo de concentração toda a
comunidade negra indo para campos de
concentração
isso marca a consciência da humanidade
eu convido vocês a sentir um cheiro
daquele ambiente cheiro de auschwitz
as dores de auschwitz e de todos os
campos de concentração que marcaram a
história da nossa humanidade marcaram a
história e fizeram com que a nossa
consciência perceber se a perversidade
ea maldade humana que está instalado em
todos nós neste momento de choque da
humanidade mais de 100 milhões de mortos
para efeitos comparativos no brasil nós
éramos apenas 40 milhões de habitantes a
população do mundo era quatro vezes
menor que a população de hoje
o cheiro de morte de sangue de tortura
de ódio e maldade instalada no ar nesse
momento cria se uma organização
internacional cujo objetivo principal é
a paz do mundo e um comitê de pessoas
faz uma declaração universal
é como se fosse a constituição do mundo
48 países reunidos em paris
assim não esse documento oito países
resolveram não assinar
entretanto voltam atrás posteriormente e
compõem o grupo dos primeiros 56 países
que compõem esse documento que são os
direitos mais básicos
cada um de nós o seu direito o meu
direito a ter um nome ea ter um
sobrenome
eu conheço pessoas que não têm sobrenome
o seu direito eo meu direito a escolher
com quem você vai se casar em diversos
países do mundo
meninas são mutiladas tem os seus
genitais mutilados e são entregues para
homens mais velhos e não podem escolher
com quem vão se casar
o seu direito e o meu direito a ter a
alimentação a ter moradia
eu sou policial há quase 20 anos eu atuo
no enfrentamento ao trabalho escravo ao
trabalho infantil as violências sexuais
contra crianças e adolescentes ao
tráfico de pessoas no combate ao
trabalho escravo que já participei em
diversos estados no paraná mato grosso e
goiás
eu pude aprender a perversidade humana a
marca do nosso país do brasil profundo
que a desigualdade instalada entre nós
já encontrei pessoas que moravam em
galinheiros e chiqueiros já encontrei um
rapaz que há muitos meses dormia em um
curso de uma vaca
já resgatamos em si um senhorzinho que
estava há muitos anos em situação de
trabalho escravo e o sonho dele era
beber água gelada
já encontramos encontramos muitas
universidades desse brasil profundo de
pessoas que não sabem o seu nome
completo de pessoas que não sabem o nome
da sua mãe completo de pessoas que não
têm documento
milhares de pessoas no brasil não têm
certidão de nascimento esse brasil
existe ele a prova ele revela a
desigualdade que é a marca que está
instalado entre nós em vários séculos de
fundação deste país em 1989
a declaração universal dos direitos
humanos já tinha 40 anos
mas ela não foi capaz de evitar um dos
casos mais graves de trabalho escravo do
brasil que é o caso de josé pereira josé
pereira era um jovem de são miguel do
araguaia aqui de goiás e na infância
mudou-se para o pará ainda adolescente
ele foi feito trabalhador escravo foi
para uma fazenda chamada espírito santo
em sapucaia no pará
ele ficou muitos meses como trabalhador
escravo e aos 17 anos ele tentou fugir
dessa fazenda
sabemos que as pessoas que estão ali são
trabalhadores escravos primeiro porque
não tem liberdade
elas são ameaçadas quando tentam fugir
estão mortas muitas vezes quando tentam
fugir
segundo porque não recebem pelo serviço
prestado porque tudo que vão consumir
tem que pagar em valor muito superior
faturado josé pereira tenta fugir dessa
fazenda junto com outro amigo também
adolescente e é preso pelos capangas
esses capangas matam os dois integram
louvá-la josé pereira tinha levado um
tiro no olho em um tiro na mão e um tiro
na barriga ele perde a mão ele é jogado
numa vala ele é enterrado mas ele não
morreu ele permaneceu vivo para contar
essa história o brasil foi denunciado no
início dos anos 90 para as cortes
internacionais de direitos humanos a
pena sair por uma decisão internacional
nós criamos no brasil um sistema para
enfrentar essa perversidade do trabalho
escravo e é desse sistema que o faz
parte
em que pese a declaração universal ter
proibido o trabalho escravo no brasil há
tantos anos e no mundo ainda existe
trabalho escravo 50 mil trabalhadores
escravos foram resgatados nos últimos 20
anos pelo ministério do trabalho que
estão querendo acabar inclusive ainda
existe tráfico de pessoas
goiás é marcado pelo tráfico de mulheres
é um dos estados onde há mais tráfico de
mulheres
pesquisas realizadas no aeroporto
internacional de guarulhos dão conta de
que cada 100 mulheres que vão para a
europa para a prostituição e muitas
delas vítimas de trabalho escravo
de cada 100 mulheres 23 são goianas na
minha família tenho inúmeros casos de
tráfico de pessoas inclusive a minha
irmã foi traficada e por isso esse tema
é tão caro pra mim
nós temos tráfico de pessoas para o
mercado nacional de futebol para o
mercado internacional de futebol
nós temos tráfico de pessoas de meninas
que querem ser modelos
eu atuo também no enfrentamento da
violência sexual contra crianças e
adolescentes que fica infelizmente
também é uma marca e uma chaga é um
câncer uma doença do nosso país porque
retira de meninas muito jovens
uma das principais características da
vida em sociedade que é a confiança no
adulto nos motéis nas casas noturnas dos
prostíbulos que o que o frei
dentro de vários estados fazendo
operações nos encontramos meninas de 11
12 13 14 anos e as resgatamos dessa vida
um dos casos me chamou bastante a
atenção foi um caso que aconteceu no
pará também é o caso da menina lidiane
sempre que fazemos operações nós fazemos
um pequeno curso com os policiais
justamente porque o policial tem que
entender que ele não vai para essa
operação quebrar proposta de prostíbulo
e baterem prostituta que já é um grupo
vulnerabilizado nós estamos ali para
resgatar essas pessoas que estão nessas
condições sobretudo e é preciso discutir
esse país machista lgbt fóbico e
profundamente desigual fazemos esse
curso com os policiais
e nesse curso algo me marcou
profundamente há muitos anos atrás
foi uma palestra com dois peritos
eles falaram para os policiais nós aqui
bacana que vocês estão aqui fazendo essa
operação mas acabou de acontecer um fato
muito grave é a história da menina
lidiane alexandre era uma menina de 9
anos que vinha sendo abusada sexualmente
pelo padrasto desde bebezinho o padrasto
muda para o maranhão junto com a esposa
e deixa lidiane com o avô e ela também
vem a ser abusada sexualmente pelo avô
lidiane era uma menina muito madura eu
conversei com várias pessoas que eram
vizinhos da lide anne começa a vender
produtos da avon da natura começa a
revender bombons e sai da casa do avô e
aluga um barraco de 30 reais
eu visitei esse barraco também e passa a
viver como um adulto pagando 30 reais o
aluguel desse papo o corte o avô procura
novamente lidiane e tenta manter
relações sexuais forçadas com essa
menina
essa menina segundo a falar desses dois
peritos que eram velhinhos estavam
falando para os policiais ea gente
esteve no local depois ela tentou
permanecer vivo de todas as formas mas
foi violentada sexualmente de todas as
formas que vocês podem imaginar
de todas as formas e essa história me
marcou profundamente porque é uma pessoa
que tentou permanecer viva como tantas
outras que estão no nosso país e que são
violentadas sexualmente todos os dias
nós fazemos ações também contra o
trabalho infantil operações e eventos em
vários estados do brasil estive
recentemente em roraima
a questão dos refugiados nós vivemos no
brasil uma grande crise e no mundo
também de pessoas deslocadas
esse planeta que deveria ser uma casa
comum onde todos nós deveríamos poder
transitar livremente nele porque somos
filhos desse planeta e deveria ser
legítimo transitarmos e querer o melhor
para os nossos filhos e para a nossa
família
nós vivemos uma grande crise os ruim ia
saindo de me amar expulsos mais de um
milhão de rohingyas indo pro bangladesh
hondurenhas para mim os nossos irmãos da
américa central o escândalo buscando
melhorar de vida em outro país tentando
ingressar nas fronteiras dos estados
unidos venezuelanos haitianos boliviano
se deslocando pela américa do sul e
também pelo brasil em roraima poucos
meses atrás eu vivi uma das situações
mais complicadas e mais tristes que eu
nunca vou esquecer eu milito na pauta da
infância muitos anos estava em uma ação
contra o tráfico de pessoas e contra a
exploração sexual de adolescentes
venezuelanas um dono das cenas mais
tristes que vivi foi na rodoviária de
boa vista
milhares de venezuelanos indígenas
deficientes travestis crianças com fome
pedindo comida e uma criança de
aproximadamente 56 anos me chamam em um
canto
eu imaginei que essa criança e ia pedir
comida mas essa criança ofereceu um
menino de 5 anos ofereceu os serviços
sexuais em troca de dinheiro
então esse é um ponto da nossa
humanidade que a gente tem que parar
para refletir a declaração universal dos
direitos humanos proíbe a violência
sexual o trabalho escravo tráfico de
pessoas
há mais de 70 anos mas por que isso
ainda acontece porque a marca que está
instalado em todos nós é a marca da
desigualdade
o brasil é um país profundamente
perverso injusto cruel desumano e
desigual
uma outra marca que está instalado em
nós é a marca da violência eu convivo
com o movimento da população em situação
de rua alguns anos
é algo que me choca ainda é quando eu
dou carona para algum amigo da população
em situação de rua e pergunta pra ele
onde a sua casa onde eu te deixo ele
sempre me alertou não tem uma casa
eu vou dormir embaixo da marquise do
hospital tal hoje eu vou dormir na rua
tal hoje
isso me faz lembrar que muitas pessoas o
nosso país não tem casa
a demanda da população em situação de
rua é demanda contra o preconceito por
mais respeito por banheiros públicos
para fazerem as suas necessidades
biológicas mas é uma demanda sobretudo
por moradia é preciso talvez que
reescrevam vamos à declaração universal
dos direitos humanos com as mãos também
dessas pessoas que foram esquecidas e
não apenas com mãos européias e não
apenas com mãos masculinas porque se
algo incomum nesses códigos e convenções
e constituições é que todos eles o maior
parte foram construídos por mombrum mãos
brancas e masculinas
é preciso que as mulheres que são a
maior parte da nossa humanidade
inscrevam essas conversões essas
declarações mulheres em poderes ao de
vários direitos que lhes foram retirados
há uma história que me marca muito que
todos os brasileiros deveriam conhecer
durante muitas décadas no brasil as
mulheres foram proibidas pela lei de
praticar qualquer tipo de esporte
coletivo e qualquer arte marcial essa
lei a de 1930 e até 1971 nenhuma mulher
no brasil poderia praticar uma arte
marcial
isso é proibido e essa lei apenas foi
modificada porque as meninas do judô
raspar os cabelos enfaixaram seio se
inscreveram no campeonato mundial de
judô que aconteceu nesse ano em buenos
aires na argentina e foram para a
argentina lutar contra homens se
passando por homens e muitas delas
ganharam o campeonato então é preciso
que os nove que as nossas convenções
sejam inscritas também por mulheres
sejam escritas por lgbts e faz parte da
comunidade lgbt faz parte de uma
associação de policiais lésbicas gays
bissexuais travestis que sofrem inúmeras
violações cotidianamente
não é fácil ser lgbt muito mais difícil
ainda ser um policial lgbt e nós lutamos
simplesmente por respeito por nenhum
privilégio apenas respeito para essa
comunidade tratamento igualitário para
essa comunidade
nós lutamos por uma segurança pública
sem homofobia diz respeito sem fio
nós lutamos para que os lgbts não sejam
expulsos de casa como eu fui
talvez a gente precise reescrever essa
declaração mas se não quisermos
reescrever a declaração universal dos
direitos humanos é preciso que a gente
internalize esses 30 artigos que são
muito simples e que garantem respeito e
é preciso que a gente internalize e
volte a fazer renascer o centro e o
cerne dessa declaração que a
generosidade humana que a humanidade que
existe em cada um de nós que é o poder
que temos de chegar até aqui juntos
porque vencemos muitas intempéries
muitas selvageria se a história humana e
de milhões e milhões de anos e juntos
nós somos mais fortes nós precisamos
ressuscitar a humanidade que existe em
cada um de nós e internalizar esse
documento que é uma espécie de
constituição universal para que a gente
possa fazer valer os direitos humanos
muito obrigado a todos
[Música]